the boy yes sir what's good bro man I
know man I'm just out here working man
zombie right now ain't got no sleep man
straight work mode man
um
you I feel like it's been it's been at
least a year year and a half since
you've been back on the show man so
welcome back I appreciate you for having
me again so far you have been putting
out a lot of music this year when we're
used to you dropping so much so I'm only
assuming you got a whole lot of [__]
coming yeah I got a whole lot of coming
for so a whole lot of coming yeah cause
uh you were you were putting some high
pressure on 2022 man you get some high
pressure for so I ain't gonna lie it's
gonna be a lot of way more pressure than
while I was applying at 22 for real I'm
just getting started for real my year
just getting started I had a Ralphie the
plug on the show and he went viral
because he was talking about how your
album was much better than Kendrick's
album
shout out to Ralphie good guy uh you
guys dropped that album on the same day
how do you because I do feel like the
people who give you respect are like the
people you're like you would really want
respect from but do you still feel like
you're a little slept on
I mean
I I just put it like this I ain't where
I want to be you family I I ain't
nowhere where I want to be I'ma just
keep working you family time I'm just
one of them for I already believe I
already believe in myself that I wanted
to I just got to put it out there you
feel me put it in a face you can't be
fun to believe that so I ain't gonna lie
2023 like you say I ain't been doing
like I ain't gonna say I've been doing
I've been doing private recording yeah
like I ain't gonna lie my year really
just start starting to get started for
real I'm gonna when you drop so much
pressure April 14th album album what's
it called I ain't gonna say album
mixtape project whatever EP okay P seven
songs nice seven songs what's it you got
a name for it yup 2K 23. oh I like it
all right 2K 23 man Balling on these man
I ain't gonna lie this might be uh
this this might be my last solo album uh
this year for real you're doing some
collab albums with people uh I got some
but I don't they might they might drop
it I don't really count them for you
know that so when you say your last solo
album so what does that mean probably
just for the year I'm really just
awesome I'm gonna just be dropping but I
probably ain't gonna drop no tape for
real just like singles hey probably just
singles for real just dropping you know
the attention span is so short you feel
me
Just Gonna Keep it lit with some singles
for real what is uh you know we were
just talking a little bit about the
Russell obviously coming out of your
your town
um so many legends that come out of
Vallejo too by the way
um what is it like to kind of see
someone like little Russell kind of take
a different approach to the music
industry obviously he's not really kind
of right now we get so much of the
street music from Vallejo he's kind of
given us a whole different side of the
coin I tell the Russell every time I see
him he'll tell you I call him baby Jesus
right baby Jesus like when we see the
Russell We Believe type that's really
really like when you walk around this
with angel wings and a halo around this
right yeah when you walk around this you
see the goat like he's showing the way
yeah and he's not he's not putting no
negativity in the world like he pushing
all positivity like I tell that like you
you're you're going to heaven for the
show like you got to like you spreading
a good message like he wanna like you
know you know because in the Bible that
they talk about that be spreading my
message yeah he a prophet yeah he wanted
them you know cat have you been to his
house for any of his shows yet yeah
pretty crazy you got the backyard going
crazy just right in the neighborhood
yeah so and they and they so respectful
he'd be on some pay what you want to
like a mug when you're doing like that
like gonna give you 100 for a shirt
right you might have some little low
ballers but you're gonna run into
somebody that's gonna even out yeah it's
gonna even out for sure probably he then
they're getting molding even outfit so I
was gonna say uh how far are you from
compared to where his house is at or is
that kind of like I ain't even in Valle
you talking about like where we from
though like yeah where you from yeah
like we from around the corner for sure
yeah like we both in the north the north
little hell is small that's like really
like it is very small it's as small as
an island for yeah like this Island's
bigger than Vallejo
um you obviously have been somebody who
tapped in with this what's going on in
Stockton because Stockton's kind of on
fire right now man
kind of the base cousin a little bit you
know yeah yeah a lot of people who
aren't from the bay lump Sacramento
Meadow Stockton and the bay all is one
even though they're not
um you worked with young slobby before
he passed away talk about your guys's
relationship obviously rest in peace to
him but you know that was a big loss for
Stockton RP my [__] Mary since I tapped
in with him like you feel me because he
just been genuine for it as my [__]
like I call that [__] like we just talk
on some other [__] not even Unknown
music [__] for real like he'll come pull
up on me you feel me uh I outline little
plays up from for him to go get this so
you send me all type of little [__] as
my [__]
RP that [__] man [__] well I really
[__] with mostly I [__] with a lot of
ebk [__] though I ain't gonna lie I
[__] with Jack I [__] with jaybo
Trey B little marble I [__] with a lot
of them [__] [__] cool do you ever
do like shows in Stockton uh I did it so
in Stockton before probably the SOB shot
I probably did a solo show like not too
long ago but that'd be so much [__]
going on I wouldn't even remember you've
been a part of some crazy [__] man for
sure I probably the last time I probably
did this uh Stockton probably like a
year or two ago I don't remember being
out there but I know a [__] did a
couple shows out there for sure